extreme weather has been in the news a
lot lately live storm hitting the
bahamas heading for the the alaska fire
we just checked is more than 250 acres
wide the provo fire chiefs record
temperatures britain is feeling the burn
so what might these separate events have
in common climate change climate climate
change climate change the fight against
climate change is getting climate change
for a long time climate scientists
tiptoed around the issue are individual
extreme weather events caused by climate
change increasingly the answer climate
experts are giving is yes the latest
iteration of that is a new massive
report by a un-led organization set up
to assess the science of climate change
it was pretty emphatic in its messaging
actually in case you missed it this is
what it said it is unequivocal that
human influence has warmed the
atmosphere ocean and land and it linked
that human-driven warming to extreme
weather we've all experienced lately
that connection is made possible by a
relatively new field called attribution
science it aims to apply rigor to
finding answers to questions we've all
asked ourselves does that drought fire
or storm we just lived through have
anything to do with climate change or
human activity and if so how much
the science has its limitations but as
it improves the answers could impact
where people live and how cities plan
for the future
here's how it works field scientists
study the environment the oceans
glaciers forests and atmosphere and
track any changes that's the what's
happening where attribution science
comes in is in the why did that glacier
melt because of climate change or the
planet's natural climate cycles
attribution science aims to check out
the list of possible explanations using
complex computer models and lots of data
let's take a look at attribution science
in action around 2013 a blob appeared
off the coast of alaska it wasn't a
physical object but rather an area of
warm water it grew and grew and grew
reaching as far south as mexico which is
where i'm from it caused major economic
and ecological damage some
oceanographers ruled out el nino which
is a warm weather pattern as a possible
cause for the blob growth and a 2018
attribution science paper suggested that
human-driven climate change played a big
role in feeding the blob i wanted to
better understand how attribution
scientists come to their conclusions the
limitations of their work and how it all
affects us i set up a virtual meeting
with stephanie herring a climate
scientist at the national oceanic and
atmospheric administration or noaa for
short how is it that scientists can
connect individual weather events like
heat waves or the blob to climate which
takes place over decades it is very
complicated but there's actually a bunch
of ways we do this i like to use a
public health analysis if you were to
smoke it would increase your risk of
lung cancer help public health officials
have a way to look at a group of people
that don't smoke and look at people that
do smoke and then understand what their
change in risk was how much their risk
of lung cancer increased because of
smoking people who don't smoke also get
lung cancer right and so in climate
change and in the climate change
research world we actually do something
very similar the smoker in that analogy
is our current planet and the non-smoker
well that's an imaginary earth in which
humans aren't pumping out greenhouse
gases like methane and carbon dioxide
into the atmosphere attribution
scientists can use climate models to
look back and forward in time
then they can model out the risk of an
extreme weather event happening under
those imaginary conditions and what's
actually happened in many cases
researchers find the connection to
climate change is pretty clear in others
it's more tenuous one key variable is
data and all these analyses require lots
and lots of it the more data that's
available the more conclusive these
assessments can be that's why climate
scientists are most certain about the
connection between climate change and
heat waves the heat related data goes
back millions of years thanks to
specimens like ice cores tree rings and
corals that can give scientists proxy
readings on temperature and atmospheric
conditions more recently satellites have
provided even more data the other piece
is do we understand the physical
dynamics behind what drives these types
of events two limitations of attribution
science a lack of data in certain
regions of the earth and how well
scientists understand a particular
weather event and its drivers take
tornadoes for example meteorologists
don't fully understand the physics of
how they form and by extension how
climate change might affect the
environmental conditions that trigger
them as a result dr herring says no one
has the tools to do an attribution study
on tornadoes because the science isn't
far enough along other events like
hurricanes fall somewhere in the middle
between heat and tornadoes still
atmospheric scientists don't know how
climate change will impact the severity
and frequency of storms in the future
how much of it is human activity
versus something else extreme events
have always been around what we're
seeing is that while natural variability
continues to play a role in setting kind
of setting things up for an extreme
event to happen what we are seeing is
that climate change is increasingly
playing a role in pushing things
up
a new threshold what should people take
away from that like why should they why
should they care well i'm sort of
sitting here talking about global
average temperature and two degrees
celsius and you know
melting sea ice um that's going to
impact zoning codes in towns across this
country that's going to impact where
people choose to live what kind of homes
they build what kind of transportation
infrastructure we create and it will
help us understand how to plan for and
prepare for our future and ensure that
we are able to adapt and be resilient in
the face of change
when i look around miami beach which is
where i live i'm already seeing that
climate adaptation at work the city
raised the streets because of sea level
rise and flooding other communities are
grappling with fires and drought
if your city is also trying to become
more climate resilient let us know in
the comments or if you have questions
about science or health in general let
us know there too and don't forget to
hit subscribe so you don't miss any of
our updates hasta luego see you soon
gracias